Joe Biden's student debt bribe is still
causing chaos despite the Supreme Court
telling him no the administration is so
far forgiven a whopping $130 billion in
student debt billion but even that
simply not good enough for the loan
dodging Bratz one in 10 delinquent
student loan borrowers are refusing to
pay in the hopes that it puts pressure
on the government to cancel them and
this has got a s you know because Joy
bear she's lashing out at gen Z for
acting like the economy left them behind
they feel left behind by the economy and
they also see everybody trying to not
age so oh please got a job but they they
have job no they have to work multiple
job job there's a million jobs job
openings in this country job they also
live through a pandemic they've lived
through the worst of times I'm raising
two genz so I want I want to just defend
them a little
bit kind of makes you like joy bayar for
a second well that'll never happen I I
think uh Bigfoot expresses exactly the
problem of so many entitled aging Elites
I got mine what's your problem the
problem is not everybody can be as
talented and as beautiful as joy bayar
and not everyone can have the Glorious
opportunity to shine on an intelligent
vehicle like the view but here's the
deal yeah when I hear Joy bear I hear
the dying gasp of a malicious
self-centered generation I'll be dead
soon so why worry she's no different
than when Joe would Joe Biden would show
that ambivalence when people would be
complaining about things going on it's
like it's not a big deal whether it was
crime or inflation of the board it's
it's not I've seen it all I really get
the sense that it's like it's not my
problem anymore it's theirs I'll be gone
soon yeah where they could just vote
them out Dana Pino why don't we Bandy
together not pay our mortgage in the
hopes that the banks cancel them oh I
was thinking about what about if you're
a young worker out there in the country
and you got an F-150 cuz you were
starting a business like a plumbing
business should they get a pass should
they get to band together it's the same
price too it's roughly 250 a month there
you go um Biden keeps saying that they
won't have to pay their loans and that's
why they're not paying them because they
basically trying to bribe them and
they're going to get pushed back by the
Supreme Court or they're going to just
lose because it's amazing to watch the
the Democrats just completely abandoned
bluecar workers it's a it's a weird like
political inversion that we've gone
through in the last 30 years it's just
shocking to me because it's so clearly
unfair to all these people who worked
really hard and paid back their loans or
decided not to go to school um the Biden
Administration has created this system
that the young people believe if they
rage hard enough then the Biden
Administration will eventually cave to
your demands and that's why they
protested and almost broke down the
gates of the White House on Saturday
night because of the support of Israel
maybe they're planning on having all of
the the blueco collar workers disappear
Harold and being replaced with robots
and I'm directing this question at you
specifically so I feel like Joy beart
does on this and um I think the only
thing that's going to happen if you've
gone to college and you don't pay your
your student loan off here's what's
going to happen the baning together is
not going to cause Administration to to
do anything more you're going to have
bad credit yeah you're not going to be
able to buy a home you're not going to
be able to lease a car you're not going
to be able to buy a car your credit will
it will follow you bad credit Will
Follow You in a terrible way and if you
have a college education one would think
they would have taught you that in some
it's some sense or some somewhere along
the way two but she wasn't she wasn't
railing against College forgiveness loan
forgiveness no she was say no she was
saying she was talking about getting a
job right but she was saying they should
get a job and pay back they they my
interpretation of it I thought that that
Sunny was saying you you she raises Jin
ear and they've gone through so many
tough times and I think the other person
was saying that it's allowable it should
be understandable she said he should get
a job and I hope that's what I hope they
do I hope those are the kinds of things
we have our we have a generation of
Americans today who have an
overabundance of the traits that don't
help your problem solve they're
self-important uh they have a shaky
grasp of the facts uh and kind sometimes
an unforgivable meanness uh towards
people uh that doesn't position you well
to do well in life and then a sense of
entitlement uh we need to be teaching
people uh better that look we may give
you a break on something and Dana was RA
the point we made a point about plumbers
and electricians engineers in that
regard when may need more teachers it
may need more medical professionals I
don't mind framing it that way but if
your numbers are right and I think they
are 130 140 billion dollars of loan
forgiveness um we're off to a good start
and if we believe we need more two
things have to happen identify the areas
in which you're going to reduce loan
reduce loan payments or forgive them and
two Congress hold a hearing bringing
these college presidents in and ask them
why have costs gone up so much what are
kids getting for it and what can the
country look for to get getting uh these
these next round of increases that you
seem to be planning for yeah we know how
well the college presidents conduct
themselves at these Congressional
hearings yes yes yeah they don't have a
mind of their own you know the these
kids have the ultimate sense of
entitlement they really don't care about
their credit and one was quoted in in
this package that we got saying what are
you going to do ruin my credit so I
can't buy the house I couldn't buy
anyway you know the house of my dreams
but you know this is all on Joe Biden
okay because what Joe Biden did in
August it is in August of 2022 he made
the decision you know I need to get the
young people so I'm going to give 20
forgive $20,000 in the pel grants
$110,000 on the other grants August or
June of 2023 Supreme Court comes down
and says you don't have the authority to
do that you can't forgive student loan
and almost immediately the Biden
Administration comes out and they say
well what we're going to do is we're
going to give you a year you don't have
to worry about anything we'll give you
an offramp and maybe in October of 2024
you can start paying again and in the
meantime they've got all these little
programs where Jesse's right it's $132
billion that we have paid for these
brats so that they can keep their fund
money budget that's what this is all
about they don't want to get a job if
Joe Biden is so convinced that he has
you know a great unemployment record
which is due to the co jobs coming back
um you know he should be able to say get
a job I made it so that you could get a
job but no so you know he's just selling
himself and they're just selfish and I
don't buy my kids were in a pandemic it
was so hard no they stayed home they
didn't have to go to school and they did
whatever they wanted to do fun money
budget yes they got to stop calling it
loan forgiveness it's not theirs to
forgive the it's it's taxpayer money we
you lose this battle when you hand over
the language yeah and you can't forgive
on my behalf yes I'm not complicit in
the
Forgiveness the fastest is up next hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else